it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day so that way turn to
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond I think something feels
like we struck a nerve with joy in the
gang over at MSNBC
yeah I think we did Laura this is how
they reacted to the idea that black
voters might be giving Trump a second
look
namely that Trump being an accused felon
has broadened his appeal with black
voters it's one black lady I spoke with
earlier today here in New Orleans said
Trump's a gangster and that means he has
cred among a new block of Voters that
perhaps have never given him a serious
look and now they're looking again y'all
don't really know any black people do
you none right none I figured
no joy I guess I guess those were
imaginary black guests you had on the
show the other night Laura and and I
suppose I don't know any black people in
New Orleans my home a majority black
City and I never go into that City to
the communities most affected by D.C
policies and actually talk to the people
that most networks ignore no joy I've
never done any of that I guess and I
guess all those like polls or Phantom
polls that show Trump has an increasing
percentage of the black vote as that's
all made of I guess no they don't like
that they're criticizing the fox poll
okay but Raymond the thing is we have to
all remember it's not just hold on it's
not just the fox poll it there are
others axios Reuters they're all saying
the same thing well we have to remind
everyone that you cannot be
authentically
African-American in the eyes of some on
the left if you don't subscribe to their
views on a variety of issues that's why
they never thought Clarence Thomas was
authentically black uh Tom Soul was
never back Walter Williams any of the
people that we featured on our show
they're not real they're fake or they're
you know they they use phrases that are
horrible like Uncle Tom so that's what
they think they're not actually
authentic so I take issue with that well
Democrats are apparently seeing the same
polls that everybody thinks is make
believe and I think they're worried
Laura it's so bad Al Sharpton is trying
to revive Trump's urging the death
penalty for the Central Park five in the
1990s
let them come and tell the rappers and
others that are being seduced by Trump
what he did in his hometown through
innocent black men
now wait a minute rappers are being
seduced by Trump he better watch that
Joy Reid's liable to tell him he doesn't
know any black people but the
interesting thing here is of all the
people trying to recall the early 90s
and the late 80s Laura Al Sharpton
should be the last one talking about
race and that period I have two words
for him Tawana Brown remember that hoax
oh yeah well and and we know what they
do to Black Americans who get in their
way uh and that's to the next point that
you were going to raise
yeah well this is the other problem that
the Democrats have and it's an electoral
one Cornell West this is West commenting
on Bernie Sanders in the Democratic
party listen to this they are dominated
by their corporate Wing they're
dominated by the militarist when it
comes to foreign policy and that he and
ALC and the others are going to be in a
certain sense window dressing the
Democratic part is beyond Redemption at
this point
Raymond I love how Beyond I love how Joe
and kamla their answer to all this with
what a new Outreach to the black
community you know consists of inviting
a few Elites to the White House for a
photo op and a listening session
Colin and I wanted to convene this
incredible group of civil rights leaders
for super reasons thank you and to tell
them what they tell us we know we got a
lot more work
there is an antidote to this I am sure
of it it will be rooted in our courage
like those who 60 years ago marched and
stood there is an opportunity in front
of us
Lord do you think this moves the needle
one iota in the community itself see I
think raising grocery prices rising gas
prices uh the crime that members of the
black community are during every day
that's what they see and experience and
this stuff a bunch of Elites sitting
around the table with Biden with this
they have to do this heavy editing job
because nobody made a coherent sentence
that they can play in Toto I doubt if
this really moves the needle with black
America but we'll see we'll see very
shortly I mean I'm not sure if nobody
made a coherent statement I'm I'm
betting that Biden did not make a
coherent statement I'm happy to hear
from anybody on any of these subjects
but don't don't claim to have the market
cornered on what people care about
because I think a lot of people are
worried about this economy and that's
why they want to whip up you know racial
fears and tensions racism is horrific
but thank goodness it's not at the core
of everything we are in our country
anymore
yeah well you just mentioned it and the
real problem here is the mental state of
the president himself and like Mitch
McConnell who you had at the top of the
show all voters have grave concerns
about Biden's competency who apparently
now thinks he's the president of Canada
think about that a drug company that
makes a drug here in America if it's
sold in Chicago you can buy the same
drug in Toronto or Paris cheaper than
you can buy it in Toronto
why is he worried about the price of
drugs in Toronto Laura none of this
makes any sense I listened to this about
four times nowhere did it make sense I I
I I I think he's a gassed he's probably
talking about have the having the um
Medicare most favored nation drug
pricing that other countries get that we
don't get but I'm looking at his
squinting eyes and he seems a little at
he seems in pain there Raymond almost as
much as
we were
yeah he said here in Chicago he kind of
corrected it he correct he tried to
correct it I mean we're so I mean we're
just so used to the mumblings and
Rumblings at this point
um and Raymond it's great to see you
tonight thank you so much and I'm glad
you're authentically you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else